welcome back to the morning toast we are
so excited to be sitting down with
someone whose name is constantly on our
lips like if i'm being honest someone
we're obsessed with who we finally have
connected with it is the one the only
frank italian hello oh my god ladies
thank you so much for having me i i'm
very very excited to be here in fact i'm
a little nervous no don't be nervous
we're huge fans oh my god thank you so
much they say never meet your heroes but
in person you're quite lovely oh i was
gonna look through the door with your
heroes
all right you're a gentle giant thank
you very very much yes i am what do you
bench
we
we got up there we did 565 pounds
wow yeah so you know i take i take my
lifting very seriously yeah can you walk
me through the like the last couple
years of your life you know you're
a couple years ago you're unknown to a
regular guy in new jersey being a dad
working construction
working out clearly
and all of a sudden your life gets
flipped upside down because you're
you're well your ex-wife is on a show
but jersey is one of those really unique
franchises where like the husbands are
just as entertaining just as popular
just as famous so you've really just
kind of catapulted into another universe
in the last couple years
it's it has been a transformation which
i never expected right i got to be
honest with you again because dolores is
not even my wife she's my ex-wife right
so i didn't know how i was going to fit
in at all if any and uh the first couple
years were a little rough because
everything in your life comes out all
right but then after that then you start
getting the dms and then you start
getting a following then you start
seeing what's going on then you become
more integrated as part of the show and
then the men became more a part of the
show here right yeah let me tell you
something whatever you see on the men on
a real housewives of new jersey is not
scripted whatsoever i believe right you
couldn't write that honestly and if you
could they would do it on other
franchises which they don't like they
try to when you can tell like oh they're
doing trying to do the jersey thing but
it doesn't hit like yours
thank you so true how do you attribute
to the dynamic like the magic sauce of
all of you guys is it that your friends
in real life that some of you knew each
other before or is it just that like joe
gorga won't let you guys not be friends
like what is it that brings you all
together in that way i think you hit you
hit exactly on it and it had to do with
the fact number one we are friends
beyond this what you see on tv
we hang out all right and i i think
especially myself joe gorg and joe
boningo we come from the same background
we come from the same areas and it just
it just hits cut from the same cloth
yeah right exactly right quality fabric
there you go do you watch every episode
no okay no i don't know i what i do is
as part of the cast we get it a couple
days beforehand and i watch it you know
on my phone just to make sure they
didn't do anything too bad that week to
embarrass my family all right
and if i didn't i you know if i'm around
come tuesday nights i'll watch it but if
not i already saw it already right got
it and what do your kids like think
about the show they're not on it that
much frank is more than your daughter
but what is their overall
take away they like being on the on the
my daughter no yeah my daughter my
daughter is is is a fight between
dolores and gabby all the time gabby you
gotta film do me a favor come film and
when she films she believe me she's a
team player yeah yeah frank frankie's a
little bit more you know a part of the
show right yeah a lot of times it's just
we go places
and we go to take pictures and
that gabby's there they don't realize
gabby's part of the family right right
right but gabby's out of everybody in
the family gabby is the most
accomplished yeah right so well you were
just telling us she's going traveling to
save rhinoceroses she's out that's our
daughter and no matter what dolores and
i say it doesn't matter she has such a
strong personality she's going to south
africa to dehorn the endangered rhinos
so the poachers don't go after them
that's awesome neither one of us wanted
to do it it's so dangerous but you know
it's she really okay and i'll see you
later that's awesome exactly yeah okay
so my i have so many questions for you
but the first is some bombshell news
came out recently that you were in a
relationship yes
and for some of us dolo frank stands
like that's it hurts it hurts it hurts
for sure
and i know you said it before and i
don't want to like you know beat the
dead horse too much but like why why
can't you make it work i know she's in a
relationship now too but like why can't
you and dolo make it work
where you see myself in dolores now took
a long time yeah all right it didn't
happen overnight um and i'm so afraid to
screw it up if it's not broken don't fix
it yeah right our family dynamic right
now is so good and it's so good and
that's why i had such an issue initially
with paulie because paulie just i don't
know he didn't seem like he wanted to be
part of it and paulie is jolo's new man
yeah exactly yes
so but no
i love dolores and i'll do anything for
it's just that i see dolores now as
someone different than a wife or or a a
sexual figure to me um it's a shame i
mean i had to be a year ago two years
ago i walk in she's in a bathtub and
we're just talking you know like my
sister yeah yeah it's it's it's come
such a long way a different place yes
exactly you guys really set like the
mold for divorce couples and you know
your family
what do you think is the key to that
what advice would you give to people who
are maybe in your situation that you
were in 10 15 years ago trying to get to
the place that you're at now absolutely
and it has to do with the fact that
remember i was i was a divorce attorney
for over 20 years so i've seen it i've
seen how bad it is i went through a
divorce where my parents didn't talk so
i had two birthdays i had two holidays
and despite what happened between
dolores and i delores promised that she
would never allow our family to be like
that and the kids had whatever happened
had nothing to do with the kids it
wasn't a kid's fault yeah it's our fault
so why make them suffer
um honestly i don't think my kids even
knew that we were divorced until they
were like 18 years old
they thought we lived separate
and they and dated other people
[Laughter]
you know so but it was uh
it's dolores is a strong woman dolores
is a strong woman to put aside
everything that ever happened in order
to make sure that our family wouldn't
suffer no it's really admirable yeah
right and i got to be honest i said the
proof is in the pudding look at my kids
yeah i'll put my kids up against anybody
i'm so proud of them yeah do you and
frankie like the show has been
over the last couple years so good for
you and frankie in the sense that like
all these young girls are like oh my god
frankie frankie frankie and all the
older women are like oh man frank frank
frank do you guys like do you do you get
a lot of dms does frankie get a lot of
dms from ladies
yes we we both get a lot of dms yeah i
imagine yeah yeah and and
my my instagram used to be frank catania
junior and frankie was frank catania oh
that's confusing
well no he got many more of mine
to the point where i said let me change
mine to frankie tanya senior oh all
right to stop because
frankie calls me up he goes dad oh you
got to see this one
it's it's it's interesting it's very
interesting i wake up every morning to
an adventure
on my instagram would you go out with
someone who dm'd you or you honestly
tell you it's uh yeah i i would i would
say if i wasn't in a relationship yes i
would definitely consider it so how did
you meet your current girl yeah
i've known her guys we go back like 10
years oh that's nice right she was a
fitness competitor and i used to train
her all right and then uh about three
years ago that's when the two of us
got together we had a little bit of
hiatus in between uh and now we're back
together and a hiatus in between is when
that girl from texas that came up on the
show got it all right came in for a
little while your timeline is perfect
all right exactly right yeah yeah
i made sure of it before i take it all
right
i forgot that you trained teresa was she
one of your most difficult clients no
not at all not at all in fact i got to
be honest with you theresa was probably
one of my easiest really because
whatever i told her to do all right she
did it yeah she was like and i would in
a nice way i would call theresa an
animal when it came to training
all right girl does not sleep
i'll get a text message at 11 30 a night
from here i'll get a text message at
five o'clock in the morning from her i
tell her this is what you eat for the
day that is what theresa wow right
dedicated to it beyond description yeah
well let's talk about this most recent
season it was a really good season and
you of course were in the middle of
everything this whole jennifer
serena
thank you can you set the record
straight on what you
believe to have happened between
jennifer margaret you everyone
absolutely
jennifer i don't know jennifer's saying
that i said something i said there was a
woman not once and i'll put it on the
record again not once that i ever think
that evan ever cheated okay ever cheated
right and i know evan very well i do
know evan what i did do is i received a
dm from somebody who i didn't even know
all right sent me a picture of a woman
all right i don't know from where or
anything else tells me this is the girl
that evan cheated on jackie with
i didn't know who the girl was all right
it didn't have an instagram with it so i
didn't couldn't follow an instagram and
i don't recall ever saying anything but
me and bill were out to dinner and i'm
gonna be honest i know bill doesn't lie
okay i know bill doesn't lie so it was
either a misunderstanding all right
where maybe i said to him i said
somebody sent me a picture when bill
went home and said oh frank knows the
girl that evan cheated got it all right
which absolutely not all right i mean
listen bill
admitted to jennifer that he had an
affair right and he's not a liar
bill's not alive no all right but to
this day i'm a guy's guy building cheat
as far as i'm because built in g that's
extreme that's extremely toxic and i'm
gonna be honest when bill literally said
that he did uh yeah yeah i i just think
he might have been drunk at the time
you know
frank coerced could you imagine being
worse coerced
can you imagine waking up being woken up
at three o'clock in the morning by
jennifer leaning over the top of you
telling you you cheated all right i i
look up honestly
night after night after night i'd say i
cheated too wow that's an extremely hot
day
very hot take i don't know if i agree
with it um
at all but i appreciate the creativity
can you give me at least a night for
effort yeah yeah all right thank you can
you give us a little insight into what's
going on between the gorgo judy chase
because it doesn't appear to be good
well obviously what you saw on the on
the reunion and watch what happens live
when they were talking about his podcast
yes
it's it's
from what i know it's not they don't
talk first of all neither one talk very
much about it whatsoever but from what i
see
no there's not much communication right
between the families right now and you
guys have started filming yeah right is
that going to be brewing
we don't we just started all right i
don't know what's going to happen
but i saw things on social media about
melissa where melissa said i'm i wash my
hands of it i'm done trying to keep the
families together right i'm done trying
to keep the families together i think
that's fair all right
yes it's fair yes so at this point um i
don't know for sure what's happening but
i don't see anything good happening and
what is the status of dolo's
relationship with teresa because her not
being invited to the engagement party
and i saw that this week was theresa's
50th birthday louis took everyone to
tulum
dina was there and dolo was not yeah the
the sandina and dolores will not be in
the same place got it all right there's
been an issue broome for them for a
couple of years and i gotta be honest i
don't even know what exactly it is all
right but i do know that that it's deep
all right and i also know that theresa
is best friends with dinner yeah okay
and she's good friends with delores but
i know she's best friends with dina and
regardless of what anyone says including
teresa my opinion as to why dolores was
not uh invited to the engagement party
is because dina was there yeah all right
but what about the wedding
listen i don't know what's going on with
the wedding i don't know are you invited
no i won't be invited you won't no i
won't be invited why not as a guest of
louis you know no no me and louie aren't
that close no we're not that close is it
good are they getting married soon like
during this season of filming that's
what i understand but they're not gonna
invite the whole cast i don't know i
don't i don't know supposedly at the end
i think towards the end of this this
summer i think
from what i hear guys
you know what's funny
people come up to me and know more about
the show than i do
nobody tells us anything right right
nobody tells us you know supposedly you
know we have some new girls coming on
this year i know nothing i i know
nothing about it and jackie is the
friend of have you heard that you know i
i didn't know for sure i went out to
dinner the other night with jackie and
evan all right and yes i heard yes all
right she is a friend of mine and what
about tracy and tiki i heard tracy's
gone right i heard tracy's gone but at
the same time i gotta be honest uh
jackie i heard maybe coming back uh we
don't know about tracy so nothing's
definitive right
nothing's definitive ever here yeah yeah
we didn't agree with jackie's demotion
at all you know i think she was had a
great season i i thought she had a great
season her best yet yes 100 not only did
she come out with respect to the eating
disorder which i know wasn't easy for
her of course right but at the same time
listen i know one thing you shouldn't do
all right is stand up to delores because
i've seen what dolores can do but jackie
stood up to dolores and she held her own
yeah right she didn't hold it and until
the laura's dolores knows better than
that to ever get physical but once it
got physical it would be you know
picking up jackie's pieces right right
at that point
no but no i thought she had and i
look at jackie evolving over the time
she's been on the show she came on as a
timid little
rabbit right at the point where now she
speaks her mind she came out with eating
disorder you know i like jackie i think
she too and i really didn't like her in
the beginning and i've had like
180 on her so i thought like for them to
pull her back now no she's just getting
started thank you i i i did think the
same thing yeah you know so on an
average when you guys are not filming
how often do you see the boys the other
house i see joe and engel probably at
least once or twice a week i see
probably joe gorgan once every two weeks
um bill aiden and evan probably
once every month once every six weeks
that's right right in fact i just said
well i just went to bill bill just did
it i was hoping he just did a surgery on
me well i had a little basal cell all
right carcinoma which he removed from my
chest and i was just hoping please i
hope jennifer didn't get in his ear
[Laughter]
because [ __ ] this is going to hurt when
bill does a surgery for you does he
charge you
uh that's between me and bill but i
gotta be honest with you
guys i that was the first time i ever
used the services of bill incredible
really incredible not only from the
walking in and it wasn't just me because
i'm watching everybody else in the
waiting room the way his
staff treats people to the way bill bill
is so professional when he takes me in
the room
we don't even talk about the show we
don't talk about the show all right and
guys regardless of what you say i'm a
big [ __ ] all right i'm a big [ __ ] all
right i'll cry i'll cry i can see it all
right so i just bill make sure i don't
hurt make sure i don't hurt and he he
was great he was so nice
yeah he's good he was good so what do
you think is like because we watch all
the franchises and there have been
husbands who have come and go in certain
plot lines and you guys have this really
magical way of totally being a part of
the drama while also disassociating from
it at the exact same time and i think
that's why you've been able to create
like really like a second group of
housewives house husbands how do you do
that like for like how do you sit
because you have so much love for
dolores and let's say someone slighted
dolores and then you have to hang out
with their husband like
with all the guys on the show basically
we didn't it's an unwritten pack an
unspoken pack that we do not get
involved in a woman's drama okay so if
they say something about our wives or
they say something with respect to
something that our wives did or xyz my
situation right we don't take it
personally all right this year got a
little bit personal with bill and evan
and i can be honest everyone was sitting
next to me i was surprised to [ __ ]
when he said that right yeah but yeah
it's but otherwise we do we try to keep
it out of all right try to support our
better halves but at the same time we
try to keep it out of our relationships
and i think we've done a pretty good job
and the guys have been a a part of the
story line i don't think it's my choice
because one year one year we got evident
next year and then it's bill then it's
louie and believe me it's not a choice
of having any of those story lines up
right for these because
they've all been through hell and back i
mean louie's still going through it what
do you mean louis still going on there i
mean with the social media and the post
and teresa defending him you know do you
believe that margaret was the one
talking to the girls and putting all the
stuff out about louie no of course not
absolutely not no i definitely do not
absolutely not i know
that um
louie has
some disgruntled ex-girlfriends and i
know how vocal they are i know how they
listen
they got some deep deep embedded hatred
towards them right and it was sort of
effective because he shared the reunion
that he actually got let go from his
company yeah he did like it made an
impact yes he did that's a company he
started which is so crazy you know
absolutely hundred percent but you
remember something you know yeah to put
it bluntly guys on am i allowed to swear
you don't [ __ ] with margaret all right
margaret's not going to come after you
unless she's got it she's got her into
arsenal right she she builds up her
arsenal and gets to the bottom of it
before she mentions it okay
and uh
yeah
theresa made a mistake in my opinion by
not letting louie talk agreed because
when he finally spoke at the reunion it
was very redemptive yeah but he can't
undo the months of turmoil that he
experienced so well said right exactly
and the entire year both myself and joe
gorg have been telling louis louie do me
a favor talk because when he talks to us
we're talking you can't help but number
one like him and number two he's very
articulate he's very articulate um but
theresa every time louis goes to talk
teresa
screaming and yelling yeah and she takes
away from him explaining what all the
questions people have she made him look
bad
she didn't give him the opportunity to
help himself thank you
yeah which of the ladies would you say
you are most afraid of
dolores obviously
i've been
otherwise i'd probably have to say
the one i'm probably most afraid of is
the one i get along best with right and
that's margaret yeah we we are margaret
huge margaret supporters here yeah and
overall you can be honest we are the
closest with morgan joe oh you are like
as a couple yes yes yep absolutely joe's
i was just on phone this morning right
because he works for us we i do work for
him yeah that makes sense oh right you
guys could start like a company you know
soup to nuts house husband construction
i love it i love it keep your eyes open
yes
keep your eyes open can't wait and you
are confirmed still living with david
yes and you're loving it i gotta be
honest
david don't want me to leave
it's you know david's got a beautiful
house a big house we just built and he
was there basically by himself most of
the time and david does work long hours
and just to have somebody there with him
he loves it and he's he's a crazy great
roommate and it's a shame because but
through dolores david is truly one of my
probably one of my four best friends
that's so crazy
very modern
right it is it is exactly right you know
when you and dolo start entering into
new relationships i imagine there's a
learning curve with the new person
because the way you guys operate your
family is not
common correct and i imagine that it
takes the person a little while to it
has to be you have to be a secure person
you have to be a secure person and
that's one of the reasons again with
dolores new boyfriend paulie um i i
reached out when i saw it getting
serious and i said holy let's let's grab
lunch or let's grab dinner you know and
he was a little standoffish all right
and no he said no all right but
because and the reason i did it was the
more you see
dolores and i together the more you see
you have nothing to worry about yes all
right you have nothing to worry about
because it used to be with my girlfriend
and when dolores was dating david we'd
all be at the shorehouse because the
shorehouse is the one place where
everybody goes together all right my
kids are down there dolores is down
there everybody's there together and
you're down there you know and
you just see and i was just telling the
story this morning all right with
dolores this is dolores this typical
dolores all right we didn't always we
were never always like this we went
through a nasty divorce okay finally got
to the point i said delor come on we got
to just uh all right i said listen just
give me a short house give me the shower
house we just built a new house i said
seriously and you could have everything
else okay okay so anyway we do it
go down to shorey divorce is over
dolores packs are closed up on the third
floor all right put a suitcase
i'm saying wow she don't seem too upset
about this but you not like it all right
takes her suitcase walks downstairs down
to the second floor goes in the bedroom
unpacks puts her stuff in the drawers i
said what are you doing
she goes i said you could have the house
she didn't say i'm not coming here right
so for 20 years she's had her own
bedroom there that's why whoever she's
dating all right came down but it's i
love it because we're all in the same
place and i'd love to spend time with
our children yeah right you know i i
don't see paulie doing that this year
although let me tell you something
paulie and i have come a long long way
and if you see on social media now and
we're busting each other's balls back
and forth
all right obviously he calls me just a
potato head which you know a little bit
of a similarity to him right it's not
far off right you know
you have to chime in and say yeah all
right seriously yeah
right all right well what i was saying
to frank before we started it's like i
thought it was so funny during the
reunion when everyone was like buzz
lightyear buzz lightyear i'm like uh
frank actually looks like buzz lightyear
yeah more than anyone else he's got
bigger whiter teeth it's projection it's
projection yeah he's got bigger whiter
teeth i made it right so he's but you
know and you'll see paulie on his own
social media now puts buzz lightyear on
all right
[Music]
is he going to film does he embrace the
show like i think more than david i
think more than david good david does
that threaten your position or no you're
just in i i gotta be honest with you i
thought
it would definitely lessen my position
here right but we're starting to film
this year and i'm getting the calls from
production
filming more and more and more than i
ever have before all right when i
thought this year was going to be a
little bit of relaxation
yeah but no so far integral to the
dynamics you really are right so it's
it's
it's good listen you got joe gorga who's
as little as he is he's he's he's over
here he's just yeah you got bill who's
at this end all right and then you got
the other guys all in between yeah right
and i'm i think i keep everybody in
between because no matter the same you
saw with bill i tried to leave and try
to bring bill back okay i try to keep
piss i just i try to keep peace
i try to keep peace i really do i just i
want everybody to get along yeah i think
you really have taken on a role as like
someone who's sometimes more often than
not like a voice of reason oh i hear it
all the time oh yeah
you know it's nice to have that around i
hear it all the time yeah and my kids
bust my balls you know my favorite part
of the season i knew you were going to
say this yeah like i had so much respect
for you when theresa was acting like an
animal and flipped the table in
nashville
and you know melissa followed her out
and jennifer followed her out and then
delores was like i'm gonna go with her
too which i was just like dolores this
is your dinner teresa was the aggressor
here absolutely you're gonna leave
jackie like with no one around when she
i mean not jackie margaret you're gonna
leave margaret with only jackie it was
like it felt so [ __ ] up that everyone
was going with theresa and you told
dolores uh no we're staying we're
staying with it and i loved that we're
the host you're the host yeah it's not
like uh margaret was wrong there she got
a whole [ __ ] table flipped on her
yeah and i had a lot of respect for that
i really liked it very much and if you
notice dolores didn't put up a fight
whatsoever she knew right away yeah you
know right away all right and we do
we really we really are close friends
yeah and we if someone of us feels
strongly about something normally the
other one just gives in yeah and you
respect each other's opinions which is
very mature absolutely she's the mother
of my children she's an incredible
mother so i would never do anything to
disrespect her no and it's been really
just so fun to watch and i feel like
we're at this place in the show where
really i look forward to your guys's
scenes just as much as the ladies and i
just we wanted to invite you on our show
to say thank you for your service oh my
god thank you use our platform to meet
our heroes
oh my god please it would make me blush
all right my god i i i enjoy what we do
doing what we do i love filming i have
fun and as long as it continues to be
fun i'd love to continue to do it do you
guys get paid to be on the show or just
the women no the women men do not get
paid to be on the show what we do though
is we get a lot of perks like we get we
get paid for a lot of other things that
are ancillary to the show yeah of course
that come with bravo all right so it's
listen is it worth the time that we put
in probably not right but uh as long as
it doesn't interfere with our day jobs
right because things have been really
really busy for us lately and dolores
and i are going into an entirely
different area now
um and we've gotten heavily into new
jersey now with the cannabis
all right so
and it's taken off and it's taken a lot
of time um but we're hoping to integrate
it into the show yeah no it's all it's
synergy it all works exactly we have a
good time yeah as long as you're always
having a good time yeah this year it was
rough
yeah the women lost their minds the
reunion was wild yeah and also because
the men were more involved than they'd
been in the past so it couldn't be
church and state exactly right
you know and again
i see a lot of social media who love the
men
overwhelming a majority but you also
have the people on there just a
housewife show why are they showing the
house husbands so much all right so it's
such a bad take the girls get it get it
the girls that don't don't right
but i thought they were going to pull
back on the guys a little bit this year
but no we started production oh my god
so the guys the guys are all definitely
we're very happy to hear that speaking
of guy content they teased on watch what
happens live that uh ultimate girls trip
husband's edition
mikey in the works who would you want to
be if you were asked to go who would you
want to see there from other franchises
i listen obviously mauricio all right oh
all right i get a lot of dms for pk all
right oh he's great i don't know if pk's
going to fit with us now i think he
would he throws down he's right yeah you
got to have thick skin with us yeah you
have to have things i think he does i
actually want to be a really good fit me
too you know juan dixon
all right oh that's interesting i love
him the guys love him they do all right
he's i gotta do and we we did a couple
things together i think it was me and
joe gorg in him and uh we meshed pretty
well
we meshed pretty well so i i think we
would we would have a good time
it would be it would be rough it would
be interesting oh my god it would be
wrong i would totally watch it
so good i don't know whether i'd watch
it i'd be embarrassed
um well i can't wait to see that i can't
wait to see more of you all over jersey
thank you thank you so much seriously
for being here everyone follow how where
people follow you on instagram frank
underscore catania underscore senior sr
all right and if they're looking if some
of our younger viewers are looking for
frankie just frank underscore katana
okay good right don't get it twisted as
i say try not to right way too many
explanations you know
[Laughter]
well thank you so much for being here
thank you guys for watching have an
amazing day and we'll see you tomorrow
you